hey I was gonna breasts my name's Peter
welcome back to Abzu it's absolutely
shark just ate my friend that's what
happened all right I don't know what I
feel about it I don't have that many see
now I only have two then well I guess
it's better that they them than me so
we're continuing this game it is so
pretty my god this kind of game where
you can stop at any moment and it just
oh god it's gonna get eaten again isn't
it did I pause at a bad spot no no no
all right now it's son of a [ __ ] shark
went through here I'm gonna get that
[ __ ]
I might get that [ __ ]
what is this front flip
hello this is where the shark came whoa
this is very unexpected they went down
there so I'm all alone now okay that was
the start of the next level I should
have [ __ ] into the episode here's
where I should have started the episode
it's cool though
we got a current going it's about to go
fast
gross hell yeah and I want to do it
really fast upward swim I can't current
too strong
whoo yeah yeah yeah I feel like I should
do the voice actor for this character or
Super Mario I should be the next voice
the voice of the people
Hey what did I just do
chillin out maxin look at this [ __ ] and
give you all cancer curves
so hey you guys are just doing that
alright
I guess out oh my god this reminds me of
journeys so much I mean I'll be asleep
Hey oh my god
can I ride you guys come on little
dolphins I can't ride them but they're
so cute
front-flip nobody good at it
I want to test it bottom
I'm really good at holding my breath
Renee yeah
I guess we're going through here all
right why is that snow notice what does
it look like snow oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
my god I'm speechless I don't know what
to say here we go here we go here cups
I sure was gonna do a flip dude come on
man what up I just busted my I'm writing
you there we go buddy
mr. command dolphin take a take me to
that ugly oh god you're fast all right
let's do it
wow yeah that's what I wanted again in
oh my god yes they're all jumping I'm
the queen king and the King front-flip
hell yeah hell to the yeah all right all
right I'm gonna let you go I'm I like to
finish
and let's write this mother hey buddy
can I touch it cool
your bit slow oh never mind a hump head
Russ what a great name
what a great name said the shark for
meditation ain't got time for meditation
only time for medication okay let's not
where I want to go awkwardly close to
the camera come on buddy you I want to
go down here
I need a drone alright so we know where
to need to go we just need to find the
drone
what about in his deep dark a
this looks like it could hit the spot
alright let me liberate you buddy let me
write you back
Aaron
hey you I'm okay
why do I keep finding these they look
like it's been there for a while all
right
so we need to go oh yeah down here
oh my god I'm sorry it's really hard to
control I swear it's not me
I mean it's 100% me all right we're
going back to the current hey ruining
corals that's not cool man
oh boy now we really got some speed
going hell yay
y'all fishes come with are they giving
me speed thanks fishes so if I go
through these I get more speed I don't
know something happens I'm just gonna
keep going through
hell yeah
should I miss the seashell I don't know
how to stop them
oh that's Verano steed I swam right
through them I read somewhere that
piranhas are actually not that
aggressive it's just they've been made
to be like really bad for movies and
[ __ ] and we got killer whales so cute
oh my god
it's incredible
I want I want to swim right now
Oh going for it hairless yeah save
Willie awesome oh no he got all dark oh
[ __ ] I hate when it gets dark okay
here we go got a Slee keep scaring me in
the back man [ __ ] creeper dude okay
we're swimming swimming swimming it swim
ah oh it's you we're fine ah I hate the
dark ocean it's terrifying you know
they're gonna pull some freaky [ __ ] at
you later oh my god I just got super
speed okay so we're going through the
portal again but let's just grow the
tree journey had a very very subtle way
of telling the story through no words
and just interaction which is a really
great way to tell a story it's really
bad for unintelligent people like me
because I won't understand any of it but
I would love to get your thoughts and
opinions about the story and what's
going on in the comments because I I do
enjoy reading a lot of your ideas it's
always interesting to see what people
interpret things potentially differently
okay let's ignite the coral tree thingy
thingy
let's not go to the wrong one like I so
obviously did in the last episode
okay let's blob you buddy that's it just
touched a blob that could it look like
someone's not just me okay cool
here you go I give you a piece of meat
I mean it seems like I collected
something and then I put it oh we got
that the killer waist or are they okras
I don't know their English difference
spike okay right yeah okay how much
English do you know Swedish I mean
Swedish damn it
ah there's a cute
I mean it seems like we're bringing life
back to the ocean but it seems like they
were okay so there are these dead parts
in the ocean that we're giving life back
- I see that now I didn't see that
before this is the same part where we
swim I didn't see that I'm an idiot
so cool I'm a sucker for pretty colors
and it's definitely a amazing like color
scheme alright let's ride oh my god is
that a what do they call those
freaky-looking one with teeth I saw one
of those one time when I was snorkeling
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me I
thought it was a shark literally threw
myself up on the beach just screaming
for help I was 12
in my defense but yes it did happen okay
turtle if you don't want to come with me
buddy then you just have to say so
alright you weren't invited to the party
anyway
this is so pretty okay so the shark has
one of those things that we need to give
life to the ocean it seems like what's
all this though just pots so it seems
like they're wooden that you didn't used
to be water here maybe I don't know
okay we got something over here
what is it done
I'm gonna ride a shark oh my god why not
whoa whoa what that's so cool oh my god
let's do that again look at this
oh my god that's so cool as I'm let me
ride that yellow [ __ ]
a Swedish looking [ __ ] all right
never mind I'll just keep riding the
shirt oh this is where we need to get
all right
what happens at the bottom whoa do you
see that shadow of a really large
creature can we go down there I don't
know how far down we can go let's try it
hey guys what's happening down here
other blue whales or whales I don't know
what kind of whales what do I pretend
like I know hey what do you get whoa
humpback well let's oh yeah whoo [ __ ]
yeah that's so cool
it's so cute all right let's keep keep
on rollin next level please you're gonna
have to hurry the [ __ ] up buddy
you swim cool slow as [ __ ] man
okay
all right well see up see you later
suppose moving on to the next level
let's do one mole one mole Abzu whoa
so pretty there's a chain going up its
following its so n whispering this game
I feel so into it just like a sex joke
that I don't even wanna make right now
alright alright that's definitely a
little bit of a puzzle going on here
here we got a chain let's see if we're
going to drag with it
I'm not strong enough no I am okay so um
yeah did those fishes just fart I'm
pretty sure I heard the fishes fart dude
oh oh my god is those oh I love those
I see I don't know what they're called
in English all right I'm Swedish I don't
know this [ __ ] sorry oh that's a blue
really that's what they're called cool
you know oh my god it's the sunfish I've
seen this in in [ __ ] Singapore now
port Agha sunfish they're the ugliest
fishes ever it does not show how ugly
these fishes are do yourself a favor
Google a sunfish they are not this fast
either oh my god let me tell you you'll
see it and you'll really freak the [ __ ]
out of me like what is that atrocious II
someone kill it kill it now please sorry
some fish no offense honestly but mate
you're ugly like how did something this
ugly get conceived that's what I say
every time I look at your mama hey a
scalloped hammerhead you're free
you're free mr. scalloped head Jeffrey
buddy there's some annotation points
what if we got Dan here though
what have we got down here whoa you got
a shell cool I'll take it
I know what they do yet but I'll take it
it's collectibles right replayability of
the video game
I love how it works with the eyes when
you go from a dark to a bright place
it's very nice very neat very swag I
like it let's these are so cute Marcia
love sees they're basically the pugs of
the sea look they literally fart a man
at manatee manatee I don't oh god I miss
the money it
let's go dude you're really hard to
control man I [ __ ] it you know what [ __ ]
it I don't need you don't need you and
follow the chains
this one here now what do we got looking
ass oh hey it's our friend we need you
come on buddy
I'm gonna name this one bada bing bada
boom
that's your name you're welcome it's
great name which tie was my name what up
guys it's bada bing bada bada man I'm
gonna need hand open this one right
perfect timing
all right mate open that [ __ ] up
that's how I open [ __ ] - yep
[ __ ] good so good hey they fought
back in freaking looking flowers here
man
I know how they talked to me so cute so
I'm guessing so far it doesn't have the
journey co-op thing where you would play
with a random player at least as far as
I'm concerned I am playing an earlier
version of this game so it is possible
that no one else is playing at this
moment and the game is playing anyway I
will check that on the next part if
that's the turn-up because I really want
to know if that's the case I'm sure
though that I played it now and then the
game is out some people would tell me
all right music is getting intense mate
a sunfish man they're so ugly I'm made
let me write you one more time just cuz
you're so ugly does that mean I feel
like that's me but honestly like how
does he even move forward
it never wiggled his tail like when I
saw it swim it doesn't move it just
moved somehow I can't I can't explain it
I guess God was drunken when he made
that ugly as Fishman
it's not supposed to be a thing
my god all right we're moving through
the underground every time i swim
underwater i'm always so scared of
touching the sea plants especially sweet
Incas are really ugly and like brownish
sea plants we have and it's just like Oh
tongue or whatever is called in English
I don't know you touch it you die pretty
much that's that's the rule of swimming
oh there's the shark dude you ate my
friend man
okay there seems to be some kind of
shark gods happening here why is there a
freaking shark and what are those
what's with the pots man it seems very
objection the style some lost ancient
[ __ ] and [ __ ] is not the right word
there but
all right let's keep going I see a crack
let's see what's beyond the crack some
crack maybe for your rice oh [ __ ] okay
we got through another another one well
we got to make it pretty maybe the shark
is guiding us that's a theory I put a
path theory sorry I stole this
okay we're back at the bottom of the
ocean and now we have to swim over there
it's so nice in harmonic
how many are there those there's one two
three okay so there's one more after
this one and then something will happen
I assume such a weird thing
the concept of being at the bottom of
the ocean and then there's another
bottom of the ocean gravity how does it
work I don't understand Isaac help me
alright let's shower in this snot blob
thing
very nice oh hell yeah oh look at those
then interact with those I don't think
it's Savas well Dan okay we unlocked
another one
[ __ ] yeah doing it alright Prez I think
I like to end this episode here this is
so much fun to playing thank you for
watching this with me I really really
hope you're enjoying it us as much as I
am and that's it for part two I'll see
you tomorrow in part three it has always
stay awesome press oh my god
oh my god Oh best game of all time Oh